happy birthday gt
so gt's been a member of my team for
i don't know it's been it's been a while
it's been a while but he manages uh our
forums and if you're one of the 8 000
authors who
write for evan carmichael.com gt is your
main point of contact
gt is uh just a force for good for
entrepreneurs
the man believes in entrepreneurs he's
always positive he's always trying to be
helpful he always is trying to give
ideas and encourage people to follow
their dreams
and uh and i love that about him and
it's always been an amazing addition to
the team and uh
gt wanted to send you some love today
happy birthday have a great day from you
know youtube nation and everybody
watching this video this clip is for you
happy birthday and thank you for being a
part of the belief team
have a great year
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday gt boomer
happy birthday
to
you
happy birthday to